9 31 here on a Wednesday morning and we
are covering breaking news in the murder
of review journal investigative reporter
Jeff gearman right now Metro Police tell
8 news now they are searching the home
of Clark County public administrator
Robert Tellis in connection to the crime
this is a live look at the scene this is
near Charleston and Hualapai out on the
west side of the valley you can see our
camera zooming in down that street there
that is the Home in question that is the
home of Rob Tellis Telus is right now an
elected official he was the subject of
several investigative stories by Garmin
and gearman as you know was found
stabbed to death at his home here in the
valley on Saturday morning after
garmin's stories were published about
Telus and a variety of issues with his
office Telus lost his re-election bid in
June the Democrats Twitter feed this
morning is full of posts that were
challenging gearman's reporting again
Telus lost his uh race for re-election
back in June and in fact it was his
second in command who won that primary
that race of course goes to the general
election but the most important factor
this morning right now again metro
police detectives are at the home of
that man there Rob tell us the Clark
County public administrator which
handles probate and a variety of other
issues within the county and that is
where that search is going on right now
we don't know where Rob tell us is right
now certainly we have Crews that are
checking out the office downtown because
again he is still an elected official we
are still waiting for some more
information from Metro Police as well as
the location of that car you'll remember
yesterday and even this morning we're
talking about the surveillance video and
that red SUV that police believe may
have been connected to the crime we're
still trying to see if Metro Police have
been able to find that as well but the
latest news again in the murder of
investigative reporter for the Las Vegas
Review Journal Jeff gearman Rob tell us
Clark County public administrator his
home is right now being searched by
Metro Police he has not been called a
suspect or a person of interest or
anything at this point but certainly
this investigation has a long way to go
we'll continue to follow it here
8newsnow.com for the latest details
we'll have live reports as they are
needed and we'll see you at noon